on parce que nous venons de recevoir
maintenant le reportage de notre envoyé
spécial dans les vosges isabelle bechler
à propos de la sphère du petit grégory
il semble que les enquêteurs maintenant
s'oriente vers une issue l'enquêté se
poursuit et nous ne détenons toujours
pas d'un deal déterminant ce matin à
epinal le procureur de la république a
démenti les rumeurs qui circulaient hier
et selon lesquelles les gendarmes de
bruyère aurait quasiment bouclé
l'enquète mais c'est en informations
sembl ait quand même trop précises pour
être totalement dénuées de fondement les
gendarmes attendaient avec impatience
les analyses graphologiques d'une femme
employée de filatures et dans l'écriture
serait très proche de celle des lettres
anonymes reçues par les villemin la
forme dm et du double elle serait
particulièrement caractéristique
par ailleurs les enquêteurs auraient
rapproché la voix d'un homme de certains
enregistrements du corbeau qui a sévi
vous le savez pendant plus de trois ans
à lépanges et dans les villages
environnants
l'homme aux favoris dont le portrait
robot avait été diffusée la semaine
dernière pourrait être le comparse de ce
couple mystérieux mais le juge
d'instruction est prudent et
particulièrement minutieux il attend
avant tout les analyses scientifiques en
cours
pendant ce temps à la gendarmerie de
bruz hier on continue d'auditionner les
membres de la famille villemin
ici la grand mère maternelle de grégory
toutes les pistes sont bonnes à prendre
l'hôtelier de dos celle qui avait repéré
le manège étrange de l'homme au favori
est venu parler aux gendarmes d'une
lettre bizarre reçu ce matin une lettre
où il aurait été question de criminels